こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんは
イマジナリーフレンドというものをご存知
でしょうか名前の通りイマジナリー
フレンド空想の友達っていう意味なんです
けれどもちょっと調べてみるね別にね悪い
ことじゃないのよなんか病気とかじゃない
んですけどもイマジナリーフレンドとは
心理学や精神医学における現象の一つで
空想上の友達を意味して実際には存在し
ない人物のことこれを今地面リーフレンド
と言いますそのため本人以外はその人物の
ことを認識できません主に2歳から7歳
ぐらいの
幼少期に現れると言われています
経験ある人いるかわかんないんですけども
妄想とか空想で友達を作り出しちゃう
みたいなで周りの人は見えないけど自分
だけ見えててその空想の友達をお話でき
るっていうこれを今時代にフレンドって
言うんですよ俺はね
弟ができるまでなんかいたような気がする
のよ知らんけど一人っ子とかいるのかな
なんか寂しい人とかて今にフレンドって
いう存在があるんですけども僕ですね
イマジナリーフレンド作ってきました
ちょっと呼びますねベッキー
あーダメダメとありがとうありがとう来て
くれて
あー今撮影中だからそういうのは後に
しようなはいえーベッキーですべき
よろしく
[音楽]
フレンドですみんな見えてるかな見えてる
かわかんないんですけどベッキーいるんす
よここに俺だけ何言ってるかわかってるん
ですベッキーちょっとここからは編集で
付け足させていただきますはいこれ
ベッキーです
挨拶
一応ね結構子供の頃からずっと一緒に行っ
てもうね普通になんか悪口とか言い合える
ぐらいの中なので結構ね距離は近いです
まあうるせえよ
耐久はそんなイマジのリフレンドな
ベッキーを準備したんですけども明日なん
とHIKAKINさんのお家に遊びに行く
のでちょっと
ベッキー連れて行こうかなと思ってという
ことで今日の動画はHIKAKINさんの
お家にイマジナリーフレンド連れ込んだら
どうなるのかやってみたいと思います
HIKAKINさんもかなり
クリエイティブで溢れる方なのでひょっと
したら俺と同じ世界を共有できるかもしれ
ないベッキーが見える可能性があるかも
しれないしもう見えずに俺が返事扱いさ
れるかもしれないベッキーも嫌な思いする
かもしれんごめんな
ありがとうというわけで明日ですね
ちょっとHIKAKINさんの家に
イマジナにフレンドを連れてちょっと3人
で遊んでいきたいと思いますなんか
HIKAKINさん家でのんびりする動画
とか撮れたらいいかなと思ってるので
果たしてHIKAKINさんはこの
ベッキーイマジナリーフレンドにどう反応
するのかちょっと気になるところですね
もうやばいやつだとは思われてるので
ちょっと500の反応とか対応が気になり
ますというわけで早速明日ベッキーも連れ
て親分散っていきたいと思いますでは
[音楽]
失礼します
こんにちははじめしゃちょーと
YouTubeどうもHIKAKINです
はいよろしくお願いします
久しぶりです
久しぶりや久しぶりです今日は特に何か
しようというわけではないんですけども
HIKAKINさんちでちょっと1日
過ごしたいなと思って
たまに
遊びに来るじゃないですかそうねなんか
いきなり隠れたりとかねただその長い時間
一緒にいることあんまりないと思うので
ちょっと親分の1日に密着ってわけじゃ
ないですけどちょっと一緒
に入れ方してみたいなと思っていいですか
[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
編集でなんかやろうとしてるな
編集ですかそうね今日もねあの
YouTube
今日公開のやつがまだ間に合ってねえ
みたいなでもまあまあまあまあちゃんと
もうギリギリの80%ぐらいまで残ってる
んで大丈夫なんですけど
頑張ってくださいちょっとあっちの方で
ゆっくりしてますね
[音楽]
すごいよ
あんまりここに来たら言いふらすねダメだ
ぞ
あダメ連絡先が落ち着くなよほんと迷惑だ
から
[音楽]
見てもいいですか
それは言い過ぎだろお前失礼だぞ
気にしないでください
[音楽]
友達のベッキーです
ついにやばくなったからマネージャーさん
に連絡して
友達
仲良くしてあげてください
[音楽]
想像通りの人でしょう
俺もね
初めて親分もちょっとやっぱわかんない
じゃないですか動画で見ないとどういう人
かってそれでちゃんとあって親分いい人だ
なって思って
良かったわそこはマジで心配した
[音楽]
編集まだまだ
ベッキーも見ちゃって大丈夫ですか大丈夫
ですか
[音楽]
編集できねえな
お前本当に
こんな機会ねえからな
ちょっと俺あっちいって言ってます
[音楽]
失礼しますね
マジで
[音楽]
聞くんですよこいつマジでベッキー
差し入れ持ってきてくれてますマジで俺気
が利かないマジでありがとう
ごめん何で日本なの
お前さ人数ミスってんじゃん
3人いるでしょどう見ても親分俺ベッキー
何で日本しか勝ってないの
俺
我慢するわ
編集最近
箱買い
やるいいよ
[音楽]
見せてもらってんだから本当にやめろそう
いう態度
初対面でしょベッキー
マジで
怒るぞ俺はさすがにおいおい
舐めたタイプ取り合って
すいません申し訳ない
[音楽]
そういう気持ちもわからないけど俺も
そんな頻繁に会えるわけでもないから
続けちゃってすいません申し訳ない
話してます
[音楽]
[笑い]
こういう感じで
編集とかされてるんです
か
[音楽]
それはやっぱそんな感じですか
滑舌
[音楽]
って
そっかなるほどなぁそういう考え方もある
か
失礼だろやめとけってそのほんともうすい
ません本当に
申し訳ない
ベッキーお菓子持ってきてるし
[音楽]
ちょっと待って
ベッキーお前ランチパック2つしかない
じゃん
すいません取り合いです2つしかないんで
3人でとりあえずじゃあ
じゃんけんでみましょうか
大丈夫ですか
行きます最初はグーじゃんけん
うわぁベッキー1枚マジかよ
マジカミッキーお前ヒカキンさんに食べ
させてあげるよみたいな精神はないのか
お前はい
ただもう一枚あるんで勝つよねはいうん
うわ
欲張り出たまじでもいいでしょうこれで
ベッキー買ったらもう全部ベッキーのでっ
ていうもう1回デッキもやんので
まじかよ行きますよ
あいこでしょあいこでしょ
あいこでしょあいこでしょあいこでしょ
お前やばいってそれはもう
というわけで2枚ともベッキーです
か
[音楽]
紅茶を
好きなんだ
最近ねコーヒーも飲むけど結構紅茶増えて
きててあそうなんですね
[音楽]
身長何センチな
結構大きめです
ね
日本で生まれてなくてでもこっち行って
結構長いでしょ
結構経ちますね
すごい
めっちゃペラペラです
[音楽]
今日言ってたじゃん
頼りたいこと
[音楽]
頼んでみな
もうダメかもしれないけどダメもとでいい
と思うよ聞いてみてちょっと頼みたいこと
が今日どうしてもあるらしくて
ちょっと聞いてもらってもいいですか
[音楽]
それは無理だろう
そうですよねそれは高望みしすぎというか
無理だよ
[音楽]
なるほどもう一個もう1個あるらしいです
けどいいですか
[音楽]
親分のゲーム部屋よしお久しぶりに行き
ましたゲーム実況ゲーム実況
楽しいよねゲームしてる時間っていうのは
そうなんだ
マジお前こいつうまいですわえこいつ
プレゼンターズマジで
[音楽]
やばいですよ
嘘かよ
[音楽]
難しいですよ
反射神経がねやっぱ楽しそう
はじめしゃちょーやってくれたのに
めっちゃ一緒にやりたいんだけど本当に
やっちゃいます
忙しいと思うけど
プライベートでやりたいよね
楽しみ多分この中にいる気がする
スマート
パレット出力
強い
ガスがある
ベッキーこれが俺の実力
がんばれ今起こせる
失礼だろ
[音楽]
ね34だからね
その生活をもうずっと続けてるわけじゃ
ないですか
[音楽]
長く続けるのが一番大変だということで
わかってることで
だいぶ
[音楽]
厳しいんだね結構中にですよ
それは俺も気になるな
どうなんですか
実際のところ
超モテるよマジですか
せっかくなんで俺ちょっと席外してるんで
ちょっと後で休んでるって話してあげて
ください
こんな機会ねえぞ
頑張れ
[音楽]
は大丈夫
怖い
怖いんだ
頑張ってるから
色々学べると思うどうなるみたいな
ベッキーは
[音楽]
慣れる慣れる
慣れるよそれは
はい
いやーどうだったまだ続いてんだこれいや
そうよねこんな体験なかなかできないです
からね本当にありがとうございます
[音楽]
ありがとう
お
[音楽]
疲れお疲れありがとう
ありがとう気をつけてねまた
[音楽]
来たね
これいつまで続くんこれ
いやもう帰っちゃったね
イマジナリーフレンド連れ込んでみたら
でした
ずっと今日HIKAKINさんちで
イマジナリーフレットのベッキーと一緒に
いたんですよ
実在するやつは違う自分で作り上げて
ベッキーはいますベッキーはいるんだはい
俺の心の中に
いや今日何にも知らされてないからなんか
前みたいになんかお菓子とか置かれてなん
かこうやって拾っていってまたなんかこう
何HIKAKINさん釣れるのかとかその
地形かなあとかを勝手に予想してたんだ
けど今日はシンプルに2人で来たってだけ
でイマジナリーフレンドをHIKAKIN
さんのお家に連れ込んだらHIKAKIN
さんにも
暇じゃないフレンドが見えたということ
でしたよかった
ちょっとまた是非ベッキー連れてきますね
みんなも自分の中のベッキーを大切にして
ね